we're walking around the uh Marvel the
Marvel exhibit there's the [__]
actual metal
Captain America shield right and he was
like whoa like from the movie and the
lady at the exhibit was like oh you want
to hold it and he's like yeah so he's
holding it and he's like how much is
this and then she was like it's 250 and
then he was like we don't have that kind
of money
[Music]
so a YouTuber has unveiled their new
secret project
we all love it when tubers do super
secret projects who Mr Beast they have
hashtag secret projects
that makes it more serious so her name
is Ruby Frank and she just got charged
with six felony counts of child abuse oh
my God
oh my God
well it wasn't obviously a secret
project
I'm like what kind of entrepreneurial
the eight passengers thing what's that
is that is it that the eight channel
eight passengers yeah who is she what
does she do I don't even know about it
this guy what's his favorite style of
channel it's a YouTube channel called
Eight passengers and they pranks have a
now defunct
um Family vlogging Channel
um apparently
they're they have they have a 12 year
old son right and he climbs out of a
window and ran to a neighbor's house
asking for food and water and he
appeared to be like malnourished
emaciated had deep lacerations after
being tied up with a rope what and they
would do all kinds of weird [__]
cranky-ish things she's like a proponent
for like hard parenting too wait what
what kind of [__] pocket of YouTube
is this so she's like a family vlogger
yummy vlogger but was [__] abusing
the [__] out of her child she would
starve the [__] out of these kids yeah
so what was the secret project you're
not vlogging I mean sometimes they would
they would catch little things little
glimpses on camera little hints of
things going on which is but she kept
the secret project really Secret
which is why we didn't want to know
about it until the police Chargers game
she was trying to she was trying to do a
drop it would be like a what would be
like a female cotton would be like like
a whip in the background like like uh
the one thing I saw was there's this one
with one of her older Sons and he
they're just like kind of vlogging
talking and then he he says something
like oh yeah like when I got my room
taken away I had to sleep on the in the
different room like on the floor for
like eight months or some [__] and she
was like
you know what I mean like and she didn't
choose to edit that out well she was
just like oh it's too good I can't take
it out so because because like if you
think about it she's proud of her
parenting style so some stuff she's
gonna hide some stuff she's gonna keep
there's something funky up here that's
going on obviously because she doesn't
know that even that like to cut that
make sure it's all good like there's
Mercury retrograde dude her name is Ruby
her name's Ruby yeah Ruby Frank is she
fine or what did she Define them
you would like her yeah what was the
secret project oh she was abusing her
kids
[Laughter]
too early yeah
oh you better watch out dude that's been
up Joe's now
probably been between his butt cheeks
dude okay so so then cops right so now
you got the kid going the neighbor's
house they call the cops police search
their house they find her 10 year old
daughter in a similar condition also
malnourished also
malnourished is what they use as a
termite uh in total the four children
are still living at home who are still
living at home we're taking under care
of Utah's Child and Family Services and
her two other kids happen to be adults
she has been charged with six felony
counts of aggravated child abuse she got
a lot of kids four kids what's up with
the husband yeah where's the Dad at oh
that's another [__] isn't that like a
another thing where he's saying that he
didn't know or some [__] he's just
filming everything is that what he's
saying I thought it was I thought I saw
something of the husband acting like oh
I I had no idea or something that his
kids were starving that's still bad
parenting in this one just focuses on
Ruby it doesn't say anything but I'm not
I'm not sure if that's true but I
thought I remembered maybe Philly D was
saying something about like he claiming
he was innocent or something I love
Philly D should ask the Philly child
Phil [__] that guy fantasy football I
hate him
he snakes me on the picks
um no so she she had 2.3 million
subscribers
um and now her Channel got taken down
earlier this year as people like Phil
were calling out the channel and what
kind of the [__] up nature of things
strict parenting tactics threatening to
take away meals like and she's doing
this on camera like she's down to just
she's threatening to take away and you
know we all growing up is like if you
don't finish your dinner you're not
gonna [__] eat or whatever but like
this is like repetitive and like she's
she's actually threatening to not feed
her children but at the same time it's
like if she's doing strict parenting and
that's her thing but she's still got
like 2.3 million Subs like that's people
that are like what's your co-signing on
to that you know well what's her most
popular video like what do what is she
known for beat the [__] on my kids today
one of them I saw was like I think she
has her kids uh make their own like
school lunches I'm not mistaken and if
they wake up too late or they don't
finish in time and they just have to go
to school then she's like all right well
then you don't eat and then she doesn't
give them like a way to get food when
they're at school
who gives you food if you don't have
money for it though you beg or you steal
it from other kids that's what we used
to do these kids the school system now
like if you don't have money for lunch
they'll still feed you like they won't
let you stop these kids weren't getting
school lunches they were like maybe they
felt like they they weren't allowed to
get the lunch were they in public school
though we don't I don't know I guess
that's we don't know that uh imagine
just homeschool neighbors also say that
they
they were concerned about the way that
she was treating her kids and they they
um they would try to do little things
like to to sneak them a little cracker I
don't know if it was that but they're
just saying that Famous Amos cookies
they thought that they that the Franks
behaved strangely and and what they
called uh inappropriately at some times
because
she would give like sermon-like lectures
over what she called inappropriate
posters of women posing in shorts that
were just displayed in someone's garage
and she she
um
she would just insert herself into
neighbor's business and then the
neighbors are like these people are
[__] weird right yeah and she got
little she has a little Westborough
going on yeah she's that Mama she's
[__] crazy can we like enforce some
just like mandatory parenting classes
for anybody who has parents or kids in
this country never do it I'm scared
already mandatory or they'll do it in
communities that don't even need it
um apparently she took away Christmas
for the kids one year good damn had it
coming
we're back kids because she would say
things like they're not repenting
correctly which is like a Mormon term
and there's only a couple ways you could
do it correct people don't know that
no yeah how do you feel about this part
I don't know I'm kind of have mixed
feelings because I feel like on one end
hard parenting is good I actually think
that I'm a [__] [__] ass parent
because sometimes like I do want to go
like if you don't finish
um
like if you don't finish in like the
time's up I'll take your food away but
then I think about his little stomach
and it's like making a little bit noises
all right here's a prime rib
that's a [__] [__] okay
get the whole box of goldfish because I
do hear the stories of like um like my
like my parents generation where it's
like because of how hard it was in the
house it like you don't really get
entitled [__] in that
generation you know like for back then
like my parents were telling me like
they all have brothers and sisters and
you know like an Asians you eat family
style so when the food comes and it goes
dinner time everyone is Boom everyone
Whoever has eats the fastest gets the
most food or whatever or whatever taka
doesn't have any siblings to compete
with so I'm like you if you don't eat
this or imaginary brother's gonna come
and just gobble it all I don't have like
these other parenting tactics is there
anything that you consciously did to
make sure that like he didn't get the
negative effects of having it too easy
though did you ever like think about
like oh I don't want everything to just
be like hand like what are the things
you make him I always so I I try really
hard to like because I know like when
you when you have like a good life it's
more prone to producing like an entitled
spoiled kid so I try really hard at
least as as hard as a [__] guy can
to like make him work for everything
I never buy him anything that he wants
he has to prove to me that he earned it
so like if we're out at the grocery
store can I have like this Hot Wheels
like what did you do to earn it and if
you could name something on the spot I'm
like okay that's cool or he'll go do
something and next week we come back
does he have to do something or does it
give you a cheeky little [__] grin
he's like I smiled yeah what's the funny
thing he said Daddy yeah he usually
doesn't I don't think he's at that like
have a rebuttal immediately phase it's
more like um can I have this and say
like uh we'll come back next week when
you get an aorta we'll come back in next
week that's gonna be forever
I'll give him that thing he's right
though that's forever yeah a long time
like we're at the uh Marvel [__]
exhibition uh in Vegas where there's a
giant hulk giant whatever Iron Man and I
think he really wanted like this Marvel
toy and then he was like he wanted it
and then oh this one was we're teaching
them budgeting so we give them five
bucks a week we're teaching him
budgeting do you call it budgeting we
call it allowance okay but then we give
them five bucks every single week and
then he has an actual ledger so at the
beginning of the week we asked him what
do you want to do with this five bucks
and then we force him to save at least
one dollar so he knows there's one
that's savings one is to spend on
whatever he wants and he writes it down
as a little chart and then the other one
is help it's like help other people like
what if Grandma needs new flowers who's
gonna help her so she understands like
GIF that's so we do that every single
week because he started bitching about
prices yeah not yet but he did have like
he's like nothing's five bucks oh no he
actually did yeah
yeah
we're walking around the uh Marvel the
Marvel exhibit there's the [__]
actual metal
Captain America shield right and he was
like whoa like from the movie and the
lady at the exhibit was like oh you
wanna hold it and he's like yeah so he's
holding it and he's like how much is
this and then she was like it's 250 and
then he was like we don't have that kind
of money
it's a lot of weeks I gotta wait that's
my whole life the fact that he's
speaking for you both is really funny
this guy you want him to buy that Shield
he only gives me five bucks a week in
your dreams Lady it's broke that was one
of those like moments because it could
have easily gone oh but I really want it
really really really want it you know
like when the kids start begging and
then then like yeah then your [__]
heartbreaks you're like oh [__] but it
is a lot well I don't want to buy this
stupid thing he's just gonna use this
like a [__] frisbee later you know
yeah yeah so I'm glad he was like we
don't have that kind of money yeah we
don't definitely that's that's great
that's great that's really smart damn I
teach the kids how to budget so no
secret projects at home that's good
parenting
thank you
foreign